[Music]
in greed over ethics news mmm
that sounds too like Asian people
submitted by jamali and panda Wow we
have an abundance of pandas where I come
from five doctors have been charged with
taking bribes to over prescribe
painkillers I'm not surprised at drug
addicts
you know it's what's [ __ ] up though
right now there's a huge opioid problem
going on because it's in prescription
painkillers and then in opium is the
same thing that's in heroin and so it's
causing people to get heroin addictions
from their prescription drugs so they
abuse the prescription and afterwards
they can't get anymore prescription so
they go on the street and then go let me
get some muhfucka heroin yeah yeah
basically because your body doesn't know
the difference it's like just physically
dependent now on opioids mm-hmm or it's
called hair on some people call it hair
on I don't know anybody the cause of
that you know 60s movie you watch us
that's a herring yeah you addicted to
that hey Ron yeah so these five doctors
they were charged with taking 800
thousand dollars worth of bribes lap
dances and other kickbacks from a
pharmaceutical company they took lap
dances too well what's your doctor like
he went and you got a whole bunch of
alcohol and a lot of lap dances from
this one strictly not that full-service
like [ __ ] but just that I mean I
don't know all that give me new songs
for three vicodin maybe they say lap
dances so it's not incriminating
but bribing is intimidating lesson girl
yeah so this pharmaceutical company
would set up these events with these
doctors where they're supposed to be
talking about this type of medicine that
they're trying to promote them to
prescribe to their patients but in these
events a lot of the times they wouldn't
even talk about the drug at all they
were just showering them also so
pharmaceutical companies bribing not
that people addicted to the drugs
bribing oh yeah people think that your
drugs have nothing to do with it other
than the fact that they're the ones
getting more drugs bye-bye yeah the
pharmaceuticals that are that have the
opioids in them yeah I got but these
doctors are like like just giving
describing yeah to the patients and so
they were just using their patients for
like a paycheck
yeah that's tragic as when a country
works I think you know this is American
American natural cures for they work but
they don't prescribe than that that's
because people don't make money by
curing you exactly there's no money in
that yeah I always feel like except my
medication for my eczema and like I
always feel like I don't know I was a
guinea pig
for the whole trial process of getting
this thing greenlit for the by the FDA
do you notice any side effects that are
no there's no short term for direct
their work what was it like it you
didn't have a strong of my guy I got
sick but I haven't gotten sick in a
while now so I don't know maybe that was
just like that super flu season or some
flu season or whatever but but no one
really knows the long-term effects is
there very new medicine out there all my
prescriptions have always [ __ ] my sex
drive that's like the biggest thing that
it messed with me because the hormones
yeah you got held up prescriptions no
just like birth control or anytime I did
antibiotics or like something like that
it was always like it always messed with
my sex drive I remember therapy made me
horny as [ __ ] damn Jeff take note you
ever want a horny
mara blue was the [ __ ] he says he's too
tired now as a [ __ ] so now I get some
theraflu for that that's what makes me
knock out because I'm just so relaxed
and kind of like I don't know maybe it
helps with the blood flow to oh he's
taking a Tylenol or something I don't
know it's hard to [ __ ] when you're
stressed
yeah but theraflu was the [ __ ] though
that's why I don't get angry sick like I
don't understand I could do that it's
cuz you're raging like if I don't get it
either but she gets it
yeah what saying because you're like
raging and you're passionate yep so like
passion for calling ass beauty by the
net is pounding the face in that's
aggressive like that's just violence but
you're angered right yeah but but it's
the same energy but you're just
channeling it oh I don't know angry sex
I just no makeup sex my angry a similar
yeah because you're mad and then you're
like then you just like you know you
just spit on them you should start
making out but you gotta be you've gotta
be friends like you got a call you gotta
pop it you gotta be cool just start
making now when you're yeah wait how
does this come about
cuz I would like to explore this if you
like the movies where you're like no no
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] you know like
slapping each other in the mix like how
do you stay angry
you don't know oh yeah you [ __ ] it out
yeah yeah okay cuz I thought you'd
speeding no no no you start angry and
then it just kind of morphs into like oh
[ __ ] this is I think I have towards I
cried oh would you pray for that [ __ ]
I'm just like [ __ ] no I'm mad you ain't
getting none of this I was just like
[Laughter]
like trying to get her mad it's just
backfiring on start the sex to get rid
of the anger and then well it's not like
you're doing it to get rid of it's just
like you're both yelling it kind of
turns you on that you're both yelling at
each other oh boy I've ever felt that
with me where were yelling at each other
and you get turned on your yelling is
like not even normal yelling like once
you get to the yelling point that's it
like it's just [ __ ] King Kong is out
so what's normal yelling like what I do
so you know what I'm like that's not
yelling yeah when I'm getting excited
like no what the [ __ ] like that's just
regular yelling what is he really like
like you'll be calm and then it's like
it's like calm to like boom [ __ ]
explosion in the buildings like [ __ ]
earthquake tsunami like all at once so
that's it's not like an escalation
[Laughter]
that's very passionate but I don't want
that River I drove the car into teleport
in turn you know
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's like drama tacky yeah that's like a
dry [ __ ] right there
breakup sex I've never done that oh yeah
that would that's good too whoa what are
these different lights what is those
kids like now it's and it saves the day
it's no good goodbye goodbye
yeah well it's like it's like you know
how they say people get horny at
funerals cuz like your ammo wedding
singer and Will Ferrell like picks up
girls at funerals or weddings trashes
waiting crime or wedding crashers yeah
not why he's here where do Crashers yeah
um so yeah when they get desperate and
then well Farrell start screaming Owen
Wilson because like grief kind of makes
your emotions get like oh I don't know
like vulnerable go there boy
yeah you need somebody to help you like
when you're breaking up you're like this
is the last time I'll ever see you and I
guess we'll never get to [ __ ] again like
when I'm breaking up it's like thank God
it's like I can't believe I used to [ __ ]
you you didn't even push off like this
it's [ __ ] sad
[Laughter]
break up with you would be so weird so
confused them like is it gonna bust the
[ __ ] dancing Solomon [ __ ] I'm all
spinning and [ __ ] I don't even think I'd
be upset after that breakup I just being
so I literally ghost in her ass he was
still the room but he was on a rolling
chair I thought I couldn't now we live
upstairs down the stairs of the Jasmine
going up this thing with the chair he's
this frozen coz he thinks the girl
doesn't see him anymore just gets on his
phone he's done but yeah so this whole
conversation started with these doctors
getting brides oh yeah yeah so is there
a legal action taking place now yes no
yeah they were charged and they still
doctors so they get their license taken
away that's a good question adjust that
I mean if they want more drugs and if
they're willing to pay for it you know
like what's the big day well it's not
the patients that are bribing it's the
pharmaceutical companies that are
bribing what do you think will happen to
humans if we don't give any painkillers
to them no they become resilient as [ __ ]
and we lose a lot more people we lose
people yes because the antibiotics and
all this antibiotic is that's not a pain
kissed it has helped humankind
painkillers have no research or day less
and it's helping people would just be
better it's just people are [ __ ] and
I don't want to feel pain so then they
they are coming out with some like super
bug that are resilient to antibiotics
though because we mean they're coming
out look that's getting me
well no it's like it's antibiotics I
mean anything antibiotic resistant
viruses are coming out on their own okay
like what do you know their own well
yeah and it's because we have so many
antibiotic like gels and things that are
like really creating these superbugs I
never use that [ __ ] I like don't wash my
hands every high school yep I really
should kill Anil does you know that a
lot of basketball players do that I
always watch them and they do close ups
of it yeah it's [ __ ] big-ass tongue
is [ __ ] like this I don't watch my fruit
cuz you don't want to slip on the floor
so you want all the chemicals on that
[ __ ] mm-hmm she's not dead I don't get
sick that's true I rinse everything well
for you guys so you get sick so much pee
you're not immune
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]